what's your
prediction about the the biden
trump debates again i just have this
weird maybe we'll return to maybe not in
this
how do we put more love into the world
and like one of the things that worries
me about the debates
is it'll be um it'll be the
the world's greatest troll
against the the the grandpa on the porch
who crapped his pants yeah yeah and
it'll it will not
put more love into the world it it will
it will create more mockery like um joe
biden did a great job
against paul ryan in 2012. paul ryan was
no lightweight no one thought he was a
lightweight
joe biden handed sarah pale in her ass
in 2008
which isn't as easy to do as you think
because she's a female so you're going
to come off as bullying that's something
you have to worry about
so the guy isn't um i think he
is in the stages of like cognitive
decline um
so i think it's going to be interesting
uh i
want it to be um
like mike tyson beating up a child
because it'll be a source of amusement
to me
um but i don't know how it's gonna go
because it's possible that joe biden
will be the mike tyson
yes because in his last debate with
bernie he was perfectly fine
and again the guy was a center for
decades and i don't think anyone
if you looked at joe biden in 2010
would have thought this guy is going to
be have his ass handed him a debate you
wouldn't think that at all
so i don't know who we're going to see
plus he's got a lot of
room to attack trump so i'm sure he's
going to come strapped and ready
and he's going to have his talking
points and watch trump dance try to tap
dance around him and if he's in a
position i know the rules of the debate
are
to actually nail him to the wall it
might actually i'm sure he's going to
have a lot of
lines too the problem is trump is the
master counter puncher
so he like when hillary's you know had
her line she's like well it's a good
thing
that donald trump isn't in charge of our
legal system he's like yeah you'd be in
jail
it's like it's like oh like you lady you
set him up
that's painful to watch those those
debates i mean there's something uh
i think it's actually analogous um i've
come to think of it
uh your conversation with me right now
some
sleepy joe i'm playing the role of
sleepy joe
i actually connect to uh joe
because they're also incontinent there's
like these weird pauses
i do the same i do the same thing and
annoys the [ __ ] out of me
that like uh in mid-sentence i'll start
saying a different thing
and take a tangent i'm not as slow and
drunk
as i sound always i swear i'm more
intelligent underneath lower but less
drunk
exactly but the result one of those is
true but not both
yeah and
and and trump just like you are a master
counter puncher so
it's going to be messy here's the other
thing in all seriousness
chris wallace is the moderator chris
wallace has interviewed trump several
times and he
was a tough tough questioner
so i don't think he's going to come in
there with softball questions i think
he's really going to try to
nail trump down which is tough to do i
like him a lot
yeah he's rea and he's like mr president
sir that's not accurate blah blah blah
he's done it and trump gets very
frustrated
because he doesn't just let him say
whatever he wants and he he hits him
with the follow-up
he's he's uh i guess he's on fox news
and he
i listen to his sunday program uh every
once in a while
he gives me hope that i don't know
there's something in the voice like
that he's not bought he's i there's no
question he's going to take this
seriously which i think is the best you
could hope for in a moderator
like it feels like there's people that
might actually take the mainstream media
into a place that's going to be better
in the future
and like we need people like him you
mean like robsphere
what do you mean like taking the
mainstream media to a better future
like bring out the guillotines okay
see you you you put your anarchist hat
back on
i don't think robster is much of an
anarchist but yeah i get what you're
saying
you